of the public
no valid questions three bulletin in
this meeting so moving on
you advise we have mr mark nor will it
improve cycling
in the right
thank you
the report is offering
in offering alternative options or do
nothing directed people down the obvious
route of refurbishment need to be spent
had the option for rebuild being
properly considered
as for the armstrong land required was
predicated on since saved by this
administration
and actually had not brought forward a
robust business plan for any of
i think councillor jerome as a ward
councillor that summary of the work
completed to date in relation to
development
it gives me no pleasure to bring a
poverty strategy it's just a reality of
life and progress is reported
how those facing difficulty through
poverty are able to progress by way of
self-help and support from the
stakeholder organizations so tackling
poverty is a growing challenge not just
in trafford but in the whole country to
price inflation that is affecting every
sector of society
climate change war geopolitical and
health services and patients are
increasingly impacted as more families
are affected in voluntary sector
thank you council but
i think
it wouldn't you know i can't really
answer that question in this missions
have participated in the strategy so far
and um
poverty is something that every cafe you
substitute um could i just ask
possible to to be told when
following the the 2021 census when will
the about um you know individual areas
within within the borough
thank you
of counsel is we are going to look at
the joint strategic needs assessment for
each ward that intelligence led with
these two strategies so um i can find
out definitively about where we're at
with the data um you know the outcomes
for these strategies thank you
not seeing that's
um and this update is just for noting
can that be noted please
thank you item nine is greater
manchester's cleaner plan july update
the recommendations are just for noting
however in time now um while this the
cleaner plan is largely coordinated by
this time now so the report um that's
bought this evening is just to provide
some updates as to progress really
early greater manchester demonstrates
that there have been no exceedances in
levels of no2 in trafford
and as a consequence the expectation of
what that entails
a chance of the most recent meeting of
greater manchester transport committee
representative stereo resignations and
such that there's been little to change
to this obviously corrected chair of
your province to information that i
haven't held back thank you
thank you councillor williams any
questions or comments from members of
the executive questions or comments this
plan has stolen um from the bundling
between gm and the government really and
the plans will not even be in place for
many years to come but this new plan is
like the predecessor in the
determination to achieve the bare legal
minimum of clean air on one pollutant
given the new who guidelines and the
cost of living crisis why not be more
ambitious like other cities around the
world who are tackling not just air
pollution but road safety and the
climate crisis which measures measures
like poverty and the climate crisis all
point towards a largely vehicle-free
city centre that is cheap and easy for
everyone to get around thanks chair
um i'll bring you in councillor williams
but just in doing so
um just gently direct you the setting
policy for the city center good thank
you thank you chair um just briefly
reflect counselor jeremiah your
frustration um and government nationally
and i only hope that conservative
colleagues that are on the table can
find some way to um perhaps apply a
little bit of pressure to their friends
nationally to to see this we're being
upgraded is impressive and one of the
despite our recording no exceedances you
know to celebrate them where we can but
i take on board your points please to
see that
trafford as a borough didn't exceed the
nitrous oxide
annual mean non-automatic sites
list and i know there are one or two
other boroughs in gm who are the same
clean air is important to all of us i
live just a few hundred yards i can i
can see the heavy goods vehicles going
past from my kitchen most of the time
where we are and we we need
clean air for our health and and for a
when we're actually going to be making
decision
with their wages or salaries whatever
you want to call it um because we're
talking about you know calls within
within trafford difficulty in the future
to you know to maintain and to run them
as bemused as i am and tempted i'll come
to councillor williams
thank you uh councillor and
some of you the the is explained in the
report we're moving away from a charging
strategy and towards an investment-led
strategy and the ca are confident and
the work has already been
commenced around upgrading and the fleet
of vehicles that are non-compliant
the cia are convinced that it can be
delivered but we need approval from
central government
um now the other thing i did just want
to emphasize is as is containing the
report this is now a participatory
approach the report outlines the
confidence that various representatives
of the business sector have in in
working with the ca um and believing
that we are capable of delivering this
through um an investment-led approach i
don't know if there's something you want
to add in your capacity chair
um no only
it is currently
the government's position that greater
manchester should
pursue a charging zone
and it is currently the position of
greater manchester
that um cross-party in fairness that a
non-charging zone gets us to where we
need to be in and um in terms of
nitrogen dioxide emissions at the
roadside which to council jerome's point
is the specific parameters that the
actions required here um and them um so
we will we will get to addressing the
question um without impacting on
people's incomes when the government
approves us
taking that approach but i don't know if
there are any other questions or
comments counseling
this would meet many of the concerns of
my residence and the the second part
which actually was the question i was
going to ask seems to have been answered
this has not been agreed yet this is a
combined authority proposal it hasn't
got authorization from government this
yeah okay well thank you very much
uh it was thank you later it's just a
quick one just to sort of re-emphasize
the theme um
and this is only no2 and
there are other particulates i know this
is let's learn the lessons from what has
gone on before with that
mess where we've had three years have
delayed and doing nothing
comes williams
thank you
just i suppose we iterate well
of western's already said that in the
desert proposals that have come forward
we have as we're acutely aware in our
own borough had some conservative but i
would just say it has been collaborative
to the comments and i think that that's
for central government to reflect on
really the fact that we have
so the recommendations are as set out in
the report krn scheme approvals
counselor ad said please
thank you uh leader
just uh briefly introduce this uh just
like to welcome the support on the
additional funding it brings us over the
next five years to help with supporting
our key route network and and the extra
4.5 million pound that it will bring
with us this addition
to the monies will actually support our
own highways capital programme that was
approved at the budget center meeting in
february and with these funds set aside
for this specific type of work this will
enable us to put more of our own
resources into the roads around the
world which are much needed and very
welcome by our residents you will note
from the report that these money
specifically for highways and which
improvement type works during the report
it clearly sets out under a
multi-transport strategy and comply
complements our own strategies like the
emerge challenge from the crossbar short
report is fairly straightforward and
obviously it's welcome and i'll leave it
like unless any questions i think
everyone should understand this welcome
it hopefully thank you councillor
outside any questions or comments from
members of the executive
questions or comments more widely
counselor jerome
thanks chair um if you travel down to
south trafford and you look on many of
the roads likes disappearing before i
rise how can we ensure that a proper
percentage and proportion of this money
gets spent on active travel
council outside thank you uh lee that's
i alluded to the point in that coming to
the mayor's channel and i hope that
members would have picked that up from
the report something that we're very
conscious of and certainly and and
obviously traffic is now uh although
aidan now covers this it's uh we're one
of the highest borrowers in the whole of
greater manchester who got that mayor's
challenge fund work so i think to see
him so i think we can proudly say that
our record on that aspect of it it is
actually very welcome in that sense of
it there so i'm happy that on the other
comment about the discipline cycle
that's not actually quite true
councillor jerome uh we've actually
you've asked those questions in the past
and we've said quite clearly put in
the new markings on the road in line
with those jeff's guidelines because
what was in the play and indeed as you
will recall the guidance from the ft set
up are clearly that because that those
uh cyclings that were sometimes uh up to
0.7 metre were actually not sufficient
for cyclists and dealing with a hazard
and and department for transport said
very clearly what we need to do is to
take those out and actually put on these
across the hall with the road it was
quite in those white lines and that
obviously wasn't the case no practical
for many cyclists so therefore by giving
a wider space to the whole of the road
and the evidence that from the
department of transport showed clearly
that was actually a safer way forward to
do it and indeed it's supported by cycle
networks from the country we've actually
been pushing for that sort of the
strategy as well so i hope that council
jerome will actually take that as an
answer because it is clear guns have
been given to us and we are supporting
cycle groups in doing that forward and
of course obviously we will continue
with our active travel programme now
covered by council williams thank you
thank you councillor blackburn
thank you leader um tfjm have 45 million
pounds to to distribute and we'll be
having four four and a half million um
do we have accelerated proposals so that
we can get in in the first tranche to to
get what we want to do straight away
yes we do the leader for you leader yeah
it's actually written down in the report
where our priorities actually are we're
already ready to go i think it says in
the report there clearly that uh that
that were amongst the authorities who
actually uh got our proposal already set
out so with quite straightforward and
simple whereas other subjects discussion
but actually we have a clear strategy
around it thank you
and councillor frass
thank you leader i noticed trafford's
adequate share of the road network grant
is already 100 allocated for with the
list of roads and appendix a did you
make us on that key road network to
concerns thorley lane received just as
many complaints as shaftsbury avenue
because that surface is frankly
dangerous and some mechanism by which
thorley lane could meet that criteria to
be considered in the future
thank you
thank you
gca exam paper 40 odd years ago and
there's nothing there and it was on the
back so thank you for pointing out okay
well not as damaging as missing it on a
gcse exam but i don't know if you want
to respond to counsellor for us
thank you uh leader yes i mean
absolutely we'll look at all things as
we always do in that sense uh obviously
uh we've got priorities for the existing
schemes and that's part of the key route
network we'll consider when future
funding comes along if it doesn't
qualify for that of course it will be
assessed along with our own highways
capital programme which we do annually
so thank you for your comments
thank you okay
recommendations are set out in the
report can they be agreed please
examination in public councillor patel
please thank you i'm pleased to be able
to bring this uh update to accept on the
next stages of places on the next stages
of the places for everyone plan uh
greater manchester spatial plan which
this administration fully supports
period
broadly during the examination in public
a series of hearings
from which a number of modifications may
be proposed in order to make sure the
plan meets the test of planning
soundness
local authorities will need to respond
to these proposed modifications
typically within 24-48 hours and this
report therefore is seeking delegated
authority to the director of place and
where necessary to me of portfolio
holder so we can respond to these in
real time as the examination is held
the practice of modifying plans through
examination is standard practice these
modifications are divided into two
categories main modifications a minor
modification it's important to note that
modifications are largely limited to
making the plan legally compliant and
sound they are not intended as a way of
changing the thrust to general direction
or overarching strategy of the plan
we will keep exec members exec and
members more widely updated during the
examination in public
this examination public 2023 at which
point we need to go out to consultation
on the main modifications so that's not
a revisit of the whole plan
the results of this consult that we will
be in a position to seek full council
approval for the final plan at the end
of 2023 early
2024. thank you
thank you councillor patel any questions
or comments from members of the
executive
questions or comments more widely as i
do so recognizing that we've already had
the debate and discussion on the content
of the submission and asking the
questions relate to the specific
delegations as set out any questions or
comments counsellor new gosh
[Music]
i want to take briefly repeat refresh my
opposition to some of these proposals
especially office space on green belt in
greenfield but we have had that argument
my question is has there been any
material changes to this plan um in the
light of these 2021 set and the changing
working patterns
since covid
councillor patel
i've issued a number of sort of
questions haven't they
um and i think it was paused to review
um
the postcovid world has been some
conversations taking place it's
something we would expect to pick up
through the examination but there hasn't
been a whole scale uh rewrite of the
plan otherwise it would have meant we'd
have to go back and recommend consulting
new homes developed along issued road
are beginning to enter occupancy
part of the wider regeneration will
involve the rings and village and it is
indeed the position of the local
planning authority and highway authority
that further development in carrington
cannot continue with the existing road
infrastructure incapable of supporting
increased use
as with many components of the
regeneration work in carrington
aspects of the work have been brought
forward before the council for approval
in stages executive previously in
september approved a preferred route for
the relief road however as is explained
in the report this preferred route
contains some small parcels of land that
are outside the ownership of the local
authority or the developer
consequently the council is repurchased
at these parcels of land in the event
that they cannot be acquired through
negotiations delegating authorities
corporate director place and director of
legal and governance to take steps as
necessary thank you chad
thank you council williams any questions
or comments from members of the
executive
council right
thank you leader i'd just like to
welcome the report as someone who's
worked on this road as
part of a previous executive role to
roll and pass this reasonably hot potato
on at the beginning of the municipal
year it's encouraging to see the
progress
um obviously as a ward member this is
hugely welcomed by both the residents of
carrington the residents of partington
who've been let down by abysmal
transport infrastructure for too long
i welcome the roads continued progress
and look forward to the submission of
the planning application in due course
um just to make just to make a very
quick um comical point on 3.7 there is
absolutely no justification for using
the phrase horizon scanning in any
council reports
noted for future reports councillor
patel
thank you i'd just like to well
echo councillor wright's um comments
there and welcome this report a few
weekends ago i stood in partington
shopping center with the planning team
consulting on our design guide we spoke
to well over 30 people
conversations about design
overwhelmingly the discussions from
people in partington was the poor
infrastructure we didn't meet one person
that wouldn't welcome this this new road
so um just wanted to to to share that
with you but thank you and welcome the
report
thank you uh questions or comments more
broadly coming first councillor jerome
thank you chair
um
3.7 discusses seeking funds from the
city region's sustainable transport fund
maybe for the active travel elements if
not it would risk diverting funds from
sustainable transport to road building
and from um s106 contributions
and i'm led to believe i think by the
financial team that um we're hoping to
get eight million pounds from s106
this could be
um could be used for ecological
mitigation
but i just wanted to make sure that we
won't be going even further than the 8
million on the s106 contributions
council william
thank you council jeremiah point you
raised about three um 0.3.7 of the
report and um allocation of funding um
versus external to trafford it would not
be appropriate at this stage in the
process as i indicated in the
introduction this is coming before the
council for development in phases and it
wouldn't be appropriate at this stage in
that process to um dictate or stipulate
precisely what funding is allocated to
what aspect of
the transport network in terms of
section 106 um you are correct and you
saved on planning committee with me the
section 106 funds can be used for those
um
those purposes in this instance they are
not being however as you're well aware
they do get used for such purposes when
it comes to other developments and
we will
um and have been
quite robust i believe to date in trying
to secure um a balance when it comes to
this development um you know my
enthusiasm sits around affordable
housing um and i i strongly believe that
we have at this point stage management
could have some clarification please on
point 5.2 it says council improvements
for 8.4 million and they had an early
drawdown or we have had an early draw
down for two million pounds
looking at table one
is that included in those figures
because it's got homes england
sorry a million pounds
um
is are these sort of two completely
separate
amounts of money
richard
we'll come back and confirm there are
different parts of arms england funding
that we are utilizing some to support
the relief road directly some for the
rationale should all the money be sort
of shown on on the um
you know on the on the uh on table one
what's shown in table one is the funding
directly for the delivery of the road
not necessarily the funding that
facilitates that such as the
rationalization
okay
and thank you could also ask just for
clarification
um
it states that
wanting to to get the heavy goods
vehicles off off off them off the main
road and there are a lot of them
will the new road be taking only the
heavy goods vehicles
um or
will the heavy goods vehicles still be
permitted to use the existing road
that's just
sorry i see what you mean i thought were
we building an htv only robot i see what
you mean now cancer willie
do you want to um do you want to come
back on that
um
on on that point council of happiness
that they will be entitled to use both
votes but they tended to be designed in
a way that it that the use of that road
for hiv is encouraged okay um
thank you and i just wanted us to ask
for clarification on um
where it would be then the safest
thought would still be safe for them to
use the existing road um and
if if then if they're going to use some
use the new road the a1 or whatever we
want we want to want to refer to it as
um is that going to be
healthy if if you're riding a horse and
and you've got heavy goods vehicles sort
of um
going very fast you know next next to
you because it seems to be sort of two
in sort of two two bits of the report
one seems to contradict the other
and i'm just wondering
how
each sort of you know each sort of group
are going to benefit from
from the proposed new road
[Music]
so um
the aim of the administration is to
ensure that both roads are safe to use
for varying um and different form of
transport we want both roads to be safe
for cyclists we want both roads to be
safe for pedestrians and what i would
say on the specifics of your question is
that we've only just had the very first
round of consultation when it comes to
the design of the road itself and the
features that it will have there will be
a second round of consultation um over
the coming months
and at that point we'll be seeking uh
feedback from residents around matters
such as crossing points around those
priorities
for people who may be um for instance
using either case is that is maximized
um because the concern is always as
councilman indicated in an earlier
discussion that um
we can fall short of the sort of
meaningful participation we want from
residents when when these matters have
been designed right and could could ask
on um
3.9
it refers to the uh the airport relief
road which costs 290 million
which still floods this new road floods
on a regular basis
is is this going you know going going on
going over this this land
i would hope we would learn the lessons
from other roads that have been built in
our design cancel the blackberry okay
thank you
just checking if you've got anything
else
i don't think so okay councillor holden
could you come forward and use a mic if
that's okay thanks
the numbers involved in this road
have always been eye-watering
now that they've almost doubled in terms
of the cost according to this report
i've completely lost track of naughts
i'm afraid from my little brain
however i've got a vague recollection
many many years ago that projects of
this nature would be submitted to
something called a cost benefit analysis
with the huge increase in costs that's
now being
projected for this project
are there any plans to actually revisit
the cost-benefit analysis for this road
uh to see if it still works thank you
councilor williams
thank you councillor holden um as i
indicated in the introduction to this
item
carrington is one of the single largest
pieces of brownfield
landing all the greater manchester um an
absolute priority for us is to
prioritize um the regeneration and
delivery of brownfield land first as
opposed to greenbelt land and this very
simple answer to your question is that
there will be no regeneration at all
without this road so i consider that
cost-benefit analysis answered just with
that simple equation um thank you
thank you councilwoman's yeah one more
than to go on
sorry there was one other thing i wanted
to ask thank you leader and
we're looking at different
organizations in order to
to fund this scheme what will happen if
we don't get the
shortfall of many many millions
thank you
richard do you want to just explain
where we're at with that and um the
backstop position
we're going through a process of
developing the funding packages set out
in the report utilizing section 106
community institution grant funding so
that is that is the process that we are
following ultimately will be a matter
for the executive about funding that the
overall funding package and agreeing the
overall funding package but we have got
still some time that we're working
through as we develop that in the same
way that we did for the metro park sorry
trafford park metrolink we went through
a similar process of developing the
funding package for that
thanks um just briefly on this as a as
somewhat of an aside but just on the
active travel aspect richard and i met
this morning with dame sarah story the
new walking and cycling commissioner
four great to manchester who was very
positive about the um the active travel
potential that this that this scheme has
in terms of connectivity out to cheshire
for cyclists and beyond and also the
fact that we were looking at both the
existing road and the new road for
active travel measures in order to
enable the choice that councilor
williams referred to so look we know
that this is a controversial scheme
i believe that it is absolutely the
right scheme because as councillor
william says it unlocks
significant brownfield potential for the
delivery of housing and employment
opportunities as well as unlocking um
connectivity to partington an area that
has struggled for years from its
isolated position
in the borough so anything that improves
connectivity um in that locality i know
is warmly welcomed as councillor patel
said um by local residents so it's on
that basis um that my support for this
scheme is assured
and the recommendations are as set out
in the report can they be agreed please
thank you item 13 is the budget monitor
for period 2. coming to councillor ross
thank you leader um very early days um
and our overspend that we're projecting
here is 2.043 million which is not
unusual at this stage and fits in with
previous years at period two
key pressures at this stage include a
children's placement overspend of
thousand pounds pressures on the home
school transport of four hundred and
fifty three thousand pounds and falling
short on our projected um strategic
investment programme as well um we're
also your note from the report revising
up our inflation assumptions for the
year from four million to six million
pounds and putting that into our new
reserve that i announced at last
executive happy to take any questions
thank you councillor asked questions or
comments from members of the executive
questions or comments more widely
yeah council blackburn
thank you it is very
early in the council yeah and
um you know we will look carefully and
as the year progresses you know about
about the spends
particularly the uh
the uh directorates that have have a lot
of pressures which you know which we all
understand
and i just like to say and good luck
to both uh
to to diane and to jill
tom
thank you yeah i think you and i have
both been around a few years and
understand the demand pressures that uh
that we face which are particularly
evident early on and i know that you
know we've got some fantastic officers
here in jordan diane and their teams
that will be looking this at this
throughout the year and you know i'll
keep bringing back updates to executive
for you
thank you um not seeing anybody else
wanting to comment on this um and the
report is for noting can that be agreed
please noted thank you coming back to
councillor ross with the treasury
management annual performance
thank you leader this report was
recommended to executive
and council later on this week by
accounts and audit members last week as
usual it looks at our annual performance
against a economic and financial
backdrop the output term position is a
net overspend of 927 000 pounds the key
variant being the level of income we've
received from manchester airport
holdings
i'm pleased to say that all legislative
and regulatory requirements have been
met including management potential
indicators
um and once again as ever i'd like to
pay tribute to the team behind this who
work incredibly hard to deliver this um
out turn on an annual basis happy to
take any questions
thank you councillor ross any questions
or comments from members of the exact
questions or comments more widely
[Music]
no okey doke so this is just for noting
also goes to the accounts and audit
committee can that be noted please
thanking you and then item 15 is the
progress report for the corporate
equality strategy
2021-2025 councillor slater please
thank you leader and
this is the sixth monthly review of our
um equality strategy and we
sorry and we recognize that the strategy
originally was between ourselves and the
ccg
but as as of june we do not no longer
have the ccg so we are working closely
now with integrated care board to ensure
that the equality strategy strategy
continues over both and sectors and
we've had some good um progress over the
last few months and just
pulled out a few items that i'd like to
just flag with exec to show that where
we are making that progress we've had 98
managers and undertake the epic manager
equality and diversity inclusive
leadership training courses and our hr
and organisational development teams
have created a team's channel to
continue to share best practice and for
recruiting managers that has attended uh
for those who attended the value-based
uh training a campaign is underway to
request for volunteers who may be able
to support the recruitment panels which
will create a diverse pool of trained
interviewees
so going forward hopefully our um
the staff that we employ will reflect um
our borough
more widely
and obviously there was a a lot of
inequality during covid the vaccine
update
uptake has shown us that you know we do
have areas of the borough where we do
need to spend more time and look at
those deprived areas especially around
um clifford and um our our awards to the
west
and public health and um
have been supporting that group and with
the
vaccine equality so um
we've made sure that we've um picked up
and we're going to be looking at the um
going forward sorry i'm getting mixed
bit stop it going forward we're making
sure that we pick up with um
health public health around the rollout
of the boosters
we've also looked at the cycling
projects that have begun and delivering
engagement
around bike bodies and supporting the
pedal pedal away inclusive cycle hubs
and from north trafford
and we're also looking at um
the
we we started some workshops last year
around um
bain and
other other other parts of our um
language that we use within the council
and actually we've had them we've had a
decision now made from our staff focus
group that they wanted to use to
continue to use the name bain but what
we're going to do is actually go out now
through the citizens panel to ask
residents further what what reference we
should be using now to include our black
asian and minority ethnic and residents
and also we're doing some similar work
with our
lgbtqia plus staff
and on that basis and currently our
staff group has said that they
wish to continue with the acronym of
lgbt plus so we are going to look to do
some work around that with um via the
citizens space so that we can actually
get input from our residents
and we've done an equality impact
assessment on the
high-speed rail and hs2
and we've done also we've taken on all
the recommendations from apsc and we are
looking to run regular workshops we're
going to engage with staff to get as
much equality data as we possibly can
because we want to be able to present
information going forward around our um
our race uh pay gap so we want to do
some work with our staff so that we can
get all that that data together um i've
started now to meet with the um
staff the chairs of the staff groups
we've met three already we're gonna do
some more work with those and if you
have a look at the appendices they will
provide more detail
of the work that we are currently doing
but also wanted to say that we did lose
um trafford death
advocacy service but i'm glad to say
that we have now been able to get them
back into trafford and they will be
providing services at stratford library
every thursday from 10 15 till 12 15
and i know that we are going to be doing
some work around the loop system within
the town hall so hopefully we will be
able to say very shortly that we do have
a loop system that works in the town
hall so that we can be more inclusive to
um staff and residents when they are
using these facilities thank you leader
thank you councillor slater any
questions or comments from members of
the executive councillor harding
thank you can i just thank councillor
slater for all the work that she um
she's doing in this area i think that's
a really comprehensive and progressive
report and i'm delighted
to to hear that as a council we are
listening welcoming and supporting um
staff in trafford and that alongside the
report that we had earlier on our
disability work i'm really proud to be
part of this labour administration
moving forward and supporting
marginalized groups of people thank you
thank you any other questions or
comments from members of the executive
coming more widely to councillor batman
thank you leader um referring to 2.5 um
people's ethnicity
how will the citizens survey be um you
know be dealt with how how are you going
to deal with um documenting people's
different preferences
um it's i think it is something
important and it you can be walking
through a minefield if you're not
referring to somebody in in a particular
way and
i think
over quite a short period of time um
descriptions or labels or whatever you
want to call
the change seemed to change very quickly
and so i'm interested how how you're
going to
deal deal with you know people's
perceptions and preferences and is will
it be done online will it be done
through through groups how how will you
manage it
we've already done some focus groups
with staff if um
if the information that comes back to us
we feel that there we need to do focus
groups with residents that's something
that we will do but the citizens-based
stuff is usually online so ask people um
a set of questions we haven't actually
agreed the context of those questions
just yet um but we will be uh obviously
putting that onto the citizens base
quite shortly thank you could have just
asked do you think our staff are
representative of people in the borough
well
i don't know all the staff and but when
you look when you look at what what our
residents when you look at our makeup in
the borough we do see that we have areas
that where we have a lot of
diversity i don't think we see that
right across the council but what what
you have to be mindful of is that um
when people have been recruited the
border might not have looked like it
does now so we have to keep changing
things as we move along and that's why
we do we've done the work around having
representative
representative um
panels going forward so actually if you
are you know if you're a woman
you know if you are um disabled or if
you are from a minority group uh then we
want those people on the panel so that
actually you would then pick people that
look like you as opposed to having three
white men sat on the panel like we have
in previous years so we are doing all
that work so hopefully in the future and
i don't know very near future we we will
see a more diverse workforce in trafford
daniel did you want to come in cancer
choking um addressed the point a
question i was gonna ask about um
process but uh i just gonna reiterate
something i said at the employment
committee uh this is it's really welcome
to hear
uh an employer engaging with the staff
so actively um and taking on feedback um
my
personal concern is that that
would then become the driving force to
make changes that's uh
not necessarily
wanted or practical but but what i i'm
keen to see and it is great that it's
happening and it's great that people are
being listened to but
there was a comment that it made at the
in the reporting planning committee
about senior leadership team for example
what i wouldn't want to see is the
council turning around and saying well
we need to change that um we need to
we
kind of losing the fed now um we need to
we need to take we need to take this
equality um
aim and
make sure it's represented it's
replicated throughout the the um whole
council if you see you see what i mean i
it i don't want to call it doctor
because it's not but it's uh what we're
not going to do is dismiss the senior
leadership team because they don't look
like
all the residents in the borough what we
will do as we go forward and once we've
you know we've got staff trained up and
we will then obviously look and it will
start to reflect more and the make-up of
our borough but you know
we're not going to
be day job i'd be representing them
people so
i'm actually declaring interest we're
not bringing anybody off sorry for the
doggy question but
i just want to reiterate it it's really
it's a really good process it's great
that it's happening
it's a really interesting piece of work
and
i'm really enjoying actually doing some
doing this piece of this piece of work
and i think that we will be able to
deliver
massively for staff and for residents
thanks
thanks can i just check if the deputy
chief exec wants to add anything at all
to
anything that we've heard there
just to give linda some insight into the
question that you asked about is the
workforce representative of our borough
and sadly we don't know for certain and
the reason that we don't know for
certain is not every one of our
employees completes their information so
we we we could do something about you
know look around and get a feel both for
true safety particularly as well for
hidden disabilities etc that's not the
best measure so what we're doing at the
moment is really encouraging our
workforce to complete
information so that we can really get
under the skin of what how our workforce
is made up
okay not seeing anybody else wanting to
come in on this uh two recommendations
set out in the report can they be agreed
please
thank you item 16 is urgent business of
which there is none item 17 is the
exclusion resolution which for
completeness i will read as follows that
the public be excluded from this meeting
during consideration of the remaining
items on the agenda because of the
likelihood of disclosure of exempt
information which forwards within one or
more descriptive category or categories
of the local government act 1972
schedule 12a as amended by the local
government access to information
variation order 2006 and specified on
the agenda item or report relating to
each item respectively iso move can that
be agreed please
thank you